russia says it's opened humanitarian
corridors to let people escape five
ukrainian cities
that's according to russia's interfax
news agency quoting the defense ministry
ukraine's deputy prime minister says the
first convoy is set to leave the
besieged eastern city of sumi but
skepticism remains after the russian
military kept attacking during previous
agreements
overnight russian airstrikes hit two oil
depots in the northwest and the
humanitarian crisis is growing as
russian forces rain shells and rockets
on cities in eastern and central ukraine
authorities say at least 13 people were
killed by shelling on a bakery west of
the capital kiev
and in some areas supplies of food water
heat and medicine are running out
russia's forces have also stepped up
shelling of the suburbs of kiev the
ukrainian army chief says russian troops
are preparing to storm the capital
a warning this report contains images
some viewers may find distressing
the people of irpin just outside kiev
are leaving
their city has become the latest front
line
there's a huge column right now around
200 men up to 50 light armored vehicles
several tanks
literally two kilometers from here on
the main street of european
after negotiations for a safe evacuation
route out of erpine failed many of the
city's inhabitants decided to flee to
the capitol
european's mayor said eight civilians
were killed on sunday alone
many are angry at the west for not
stepping in
tell the whole world that they should
help why aren't they helping the
americans and the british where are the
planes shout to the world get everyone
to help france germany britain should
help
far to the east of kiev in ukraine's
second largest city kharkiv
the emergency hospital is full of
wounded civilians
on the 25th we were shelled my brother
and i came to give blood and were
shelled
the blood transfusion center was shelled
we had just left the center and we were
shelled by russian occupiers
my mother died the next day
and i remained in hospital with shrapnel
wounds in my legs
patients can hear the bombs outside as
russian artillery and airstrikes rain
deadly munitions on harkief
here too another appeal to the rest of
the world to intervene
i'm just begging the whole of society
please get together and help to close
the skies over ukraine help our military
save our civilians
but at the moment nato has decided not
to close the airspace citing the risk of
starting a much larger war with russia
people here are holding on but it is
unclear what will remain of their city
if russian bombardment continues at this
rate
i'm joined now by our correspondent
matthias belinga in the ukrainian
capital kiev
russian army chiefs say that russian
troops are preparing to storm the
capital what preparations
are you seeing getting underway matthias
i think the capital of course uh uh the
people here have known that they have
been a prime target from the day from
day one and uh that russians would
eventually try to storm the capital or
to close the ring around the capital so
uh the ukrainian military seems to have
put in uh quite a lot of forces to
defend the capital we haven't seen the
russian lines advancing in days uh the
sites are fighting we just saw european
uh in in this uh report
the sites of fighting are still the same
and uh
we aren't seeing any
significant advances of course um there
is always the fear that russia might
regroup and try to storm the capital
people here in the capital uh have
prepared there's a lot of military in
the streets roadblocks etc um but also
many people of course have fled the
capital uh as you can see behind me
there are very few people on the streets
right now those whom you see they try to
to do not to stay out too long if you
most people that you see they're either
walking a dog or they are carrying
groceries or something uh so people go
out on the street for their for their
needs but people don't stay a long time
on the streets of course the situation
has been and is tense here
matthias what about the dangers of
fleeing other is there any progress on
these humanitarian corridors
well the most uh the worst place in
ukraine probably now is mariupol
although there are other places where
the situation is also very bad we've
just so you've seen two of them in the
report kharkiv and these suburbs of kiev
but mariupol has been shut off for days
now for for more than uh for more than a
week so no supplies entering the city
infrastructure damage no water
no electricity
we also have few messages out of the
city due to that lack of electricity
people cannot charge their phones and
call their relatives for example
and humanitarian corridors be it that
people get out of the city or to bring
goods and and relief
goods into the city
have failed so far so this is definitely
one of the places where help is bitterly
needed
is another one as we have seen i think
to my latest information trains have
still been able to leave the city so
so so people have left kharkiv but it is
very difficult to get out of there under
constant shelling and the
capacities are very limited of these
trains and so um
there are quite a few places now where
suffering is really really big now
just how easy or difficult is it to get
out of the capital where you are we've
seen some heartbreaking scenes in kiev's
main station
yes people are trying to still trying to
leave the capital there are trains
running we the the station is crowded um
it's a lot of people
those who have been able to evacuate
from these suburbs where the fighting is
going on they have arrived yesterday at
the train station and tried to leave
further but also other people from other
suburbs where a russian advance might
might arrive in the in the in the next
few days so it's the
suburban trains carrying people to the
main station and then from there they're
trying to get on any train that goes
west to l leave at the polish border
usgorod at the slovakian border or
somewhere there um of course uh
people here are are prepared or are
fearing that things might get much worse
still in the next few days and what
about food and medicine things like that
getting through to the cities these
cities under siege
that's the problem the city is under
siege like mariupol which is completely
under siege or those who are uh
hard to reach because of fighting
they are lacking medical supplies they
are lacking a a
a lot of basic supplies and of course
the situation is very bad also for those
who have chronic diseases for example um
it's it's a big humanitarian disaster
mathias berger thank you very much for
your reporting from kiev in ukraine
and from kiev i'm joined now by
innosovson a member of the ukrainian
parliament welcome to dw you know we
last spoke to you a week ago how has
your personal situation changed
well i uh was saying the last time we
spoke that i think that i was staying
with some friends
in the city of cave but
they decided to leave the city so
actually i have had to move to some
other friends who are living not in the
city but close to the city in kiev
region
uh because
well like many other people
my friends decided to leave because it
is not safe to say in the city because
everyone have seen what russians are
doing in a neighboring city of
philippines that is just a genocide them
shooting at people with the children who
are trying to be evacuated is just
unthinkable so i think now many
civilians in kiev who are not directly
engaged in and into any activities of
supporting the infrastructure or uh
directly involved in the the defense of
the city are trying to escape so that
not to be held hostages uh in the city
as as people in european are right now
so my personal situation has changed a
bit because i i still can't leave i can
stay in my own place it's too too many
floors up so i just can't so i was i had
to look for another place to to stay and
that's my friends now other friends
living close to kiev but not in the city
itself
and and so many people have to move so
many people can be living in their
houses
so many people are trying to escape the
city right now just because we are
seeing that the russians
are doing everything possible to get
into the city we really appreciate and
we pray for for the health and
well-being of the ukrainian army who are
doing unthinkable in terms of preventing
them from entering the city but what
they're doing right now the russians
doing is just it's incomprehensible
we know now that they were given direct
order to uh open fire on civilians
apparently they're doing that because
they can't proceed militarily they can't
really defeat the ukrainian army
ukrainian army is actually pushing them
back from the position that they first
hold like around the city of
ukraine and army did push them further
from the city of harkev
in mako live they are trying to get into
the city of macaulay but the city is
fighting back so harsh and actually is
pushing russians further so ukrainian
army is doing unbelievably well in in
those terms and because of that they
decide they will target the civilians so
now many civilians in the city are
trying to escape so that not to create
additional burden for the ukrainian army
so that the ukrainian army can
concentrate on the main job which is
killing russians and fighting them
and not being distracted by by
protecting civilians to an extent to
which it is possible overall
could you tell me about the russians
announcement of these humanitarian
corridors opening uh how credible are
they and how safe are they for people to
use
it's uh
well well
the world needs to accept that every
time russians are opening up their mouth
they're about to tell a lie
they have been lying about those
humanitarian corridors in mariopol they
did promise humanitarian corridors and
then they did the the
most cruel thing imaginable
they set up landmines in the place where
people were supposed to gather to leave
and those were mainly women with small
children it's actually a great luck that
the ukrainian army learned about that
literally minutes before they were about
to blow up those landmines and manage to
move the people away from from that spot
in european uh two
days ago they did promise a humanitarian
corridor people were sitting in in
shelters and basements for for a week
and they did promise that and then they
opened fire on those people and i was
reading a post on facebook by a man who
was saying that uh and i'm quoting and
then i saw a bomb flowing into our
direction and then i saw two of my kids
up in the air very high so high that it
seems they were higher than this this
george nearby and now they are both dead
and his wife was wounded and she was
taken to the hospital and she died
several hours after that
this is what they're doing they can't
proceed militarily they can't be
fighting ukrainian army just because it
is so strong so well motivated and and
so professional so they're targeting the
civilians so no we can't trust anything
they're saying right now if they open
humanitarian corridors we accept
as a norm that they will try to open
fire on people in that corridor that is
what they have been doing so far so we
just can't trust them and not no no one
should be trusting them now in a on this
international women's day what's your
message to the women of ukraine during
this war
i have one and only message is to stay
strong
to
continue doing what they're doing
because with all the efforts the joint
efforts of the whole of the ukrainian
society
we did manage to stand up to putin as
much as we did before
and i know women are choosing different
paths many women are taking care of
their kids and just
evacuating them to other countries i've
been talking to some of those women and
they do feel the guilt that they left
the country no one should be feeling the
guilt except for for russians right now
although i'm not uh think i don't think
that they are capable of that feeling
i'm i'm extremely proud of the ukrainian
women and i know that the only thing
uh that ukrainian women want right now
is to be able to get back home to get
back to their lives and to continue
living their lives as it was two weeks
ago but in order for that to happen we
do need support from the west we do need
support so badly because we wouldn't be
able to to go back to our lives to
rebuild in our country
if the west will continue to trade with
russia i'm i'm talking to you now and
i'm asking everyone who's listening to
this please please please stop any trade
with russia right now
any words of phasing out uh
slow phasing out of russian gas and oil
are incomprehensible to me unthinkable
and they are a betrayal of everything
the west stands for
any euro that goes to russia right now
is being used to buy weapons with which
they will be killing ukrainian children
and women so we are asking for a full
embargo on behalf of all the women of
ukraine of all people here in ukraine on
behalf of our children and then of
course we're asking for support from
here because they're just bombarding our
cities they're killing our civilians in
in in great numbers i just saw pictures
from suma today there are several
casualties among children again because
of the aviation hit that they set up the
bomb from air and we can't really defend
ourselves against that so we asking for
support from air because otherwise no
matter how brave ukrainian men and women
are
no matter to what extent they go to to
protect their lives that wouldn't work
because no one can be protected from
bomb falling on your head
now call for help uh going to western
leaders i hope they're listening
innos offsun a member of the ukrainian
parliament thank you very much for
coming on the show today
thank you
you